yeah so who are the watchmen the
watchmen was a group
created a comic uh storm by frank miller
pretty poor at a movie annotation
um yeah watchmen were a group which were
created for the sole purpose of
protecting chris
right right which which did not work at
all
they're broken up at this point when uh
when uh it was revealed that some
members of the watchmen were actively
involved with trolling curse oh my god
that's backstabbing the watchman this is
why it's such a [ __ ] mess like every
single person involved is you know
has questionable motives yeah because i
only found out about the watchman from
the the recent events right um and
there's like there's like three or four
other groups or something that we're all
involved
in all this stuff and they all have
their own names
when did documenting chris really reach
its peak of popularity
peak of popularity well now now it's
very popular yeah but you know before
this you know i definitely felt like
there was an increase people who are
benefiting and profiting off of chris in
many ways
by making content around chris
um
in a almost harmful way
yeah definitely a more recent phenomenon
right right
i think
which is i feel like where it started
you know it was kind of improving yeah
and chris was not really involving much
and people were not really trolling
chris as much
and then when the popularity of
documenting chris i swear it feels like
it then became started going backwards
and this trolling starting to get worse
again and
kind of coincides with the idea guys
song i know the idea guys yeah guys
what's that it's uh another group
another trolling group
which is how many trolling groups are
there
there's absolutely i just love the names
there's a new one every month yeah okay
okay so the idea guys so the idea guys
were very detrimental to to chris's
psyche because they convinced chris that
all these uh different alternate
realities alternate dimensions of like
anime land and all these all these
cartoons actually existed and you could
travel to them
yeah they were the ones yeah okay yeah
so and to this day chris still believes
crystal believes that they can access
this different dimension yes and chris
actually believed that at some points
they were possessed by like sonichu and
other other characters that they were
sonichu right right or something like
that like they were like it was it was
santa speaking through their body for
like a solid
don't worry about it don't worry about
it
this is a bit too much for me man
anyway um yeah
sonichu was
apparently talking through chris's body
for about half a year honestly it's just
like you can't explain like it's so hard
to keep up with this because even you
know when we watch the whole series in
depth it is so confusing and there's so
much stuff and we we've barely even
touched on the fact that one of the main
aspects of what chris was doing was
making a comic about sonichu and all the
stuff that's what really started the
whole attention on chris because their
comic was so crazy and outlandish and
people realized that chris was actually
using the comic as a way to live out
their own fantasies
you know like uh
getting yourself inside like like a
self-made was it for
yeah the main character was chris
basically so they believed they were
sonichu right yeah for a little bit and
then there was there were other
characters as well right from whatever
those like rose shoes rostru is
sonichu's love interest and wife yeah
yeah and there's also i i believe chris
also many points would include real
people that would die or
yeah yeah
or something right
they would they would be the main
villains but no one actually died
actually
in chris's comments because chris
believed that quickville was real
and they didn't want to cause that much
harm to the characters because they
would feel hurt
right right you know i really believe
that this is i say right right like
yeah i totally like that
i totally understand what's being said
here yes i'm totally following what's
going on right now also you know one
other thing that i also found uh very uh
worrying uh was uh
chris's spending
um and lack of financial uh okay where
did chris get an income from now i'm
curious chris has uh a social
security or
disability payment called which which
chris calls the tug boat
uh it's about 800 a month okay and this
is what chris uses to uh pay off credit
card debts and buy legos
which brings him in which which brings
chris into more debts right uh chris
gets money and immediately spends it on
like toys legos
yeah which is very disturbing because uh
i think chris's mother at the time
wasn't working either very old
and
they were mainly relying on them
they've already been like
no one's been working in that family
since since the 90s i believe right
right right there's a very uh very
chilling video later on where chris is
getting uh their mother to
promote
chris's selling of merchandise yes and
saying that they need
money for food and stuff right there's
several videos like that it's very
concerning like merch is in like what
handmade merch by chris oh it's like the
sony true medallions and stuff like that
right yeah there were medallions there
were um
signed photos i believe as well and
stuff like that yeah oh geez and it's
all very concerning i assume it's the
trolls that are buying
that kind of stuff i mean just to like
fuel the fire i guess at this point are
they really trolls are they just like
almost like fans
people want to get in on it it kind of
sounds like a symbiotic relationship
yeah right where chris feeds the trolls
and there's trolls
yeah it just doesn't end yeah and by
acquiring
objects from chris they become part of
christopher in this yeah that's no no
that's serious these people are very
invested in them i love that song
i love
i i i enjoy i really enjoy keeping up
with it but also i do feel like i'm
consuming something bad like
i am taking part and helping and fueling
a very dark side of the internet yeah
but it's also just so insanely
fascinating just because again we've
never had
anything like this in the history of the
internet i feel like it's it's so
it's so outlandish right like it's is is
it i'd argue in the history of the world
honestly like it's it's just so
everything about it is just so
outlandish it just doesn't sound real
yeah because everything that should have
protected chris failed right i think
that should have been a safety it it
feels like this this is almost like a
case study you know yeah of how not to
parent how how not to
how not to act on the internet
literally a case study of how not to do
everything yeah it feels like anything
about this just don't do it yeah do you
feel you know when you're
because obviously you're making
documentary yeah how do you handle
dealing with like the i guess the moral
implications of it sometimes and
struggling with that if you if you do it
all like i usually don't yeah you just
like whatever just power through yeah
because because i i can listen i
convince myself that i'm just
documenting it's all right i agree you
know i i don't
see what you're doing as anything
inappropriate or wrong by any means
right yeah because it's not like you're
like one of the trolls that's it's
information
like it's already existed out there but
i think by watching it in its entirety
or watching it in parts you really do
just end up feeling sad about the whole
situation yeah whereas i feel like if
you hear little bits
and and you get very tailored
information in a way that leaves out
important details
you might be more likely to participate
or fuel trolls to join in whereas if you
watch i feel like if you watch the
documentary there's no way you can be
sitting there thinking yeah i want to
join in trolls yeah you're just like
[ __ ] man jesus yeah definitely